welcome to this video playing keep on
movin on movin German flag let's see
yeah probably the bank oh no wow turn a
min de was playing this stuff oh it's a
very new account only a very little
games played yeah this is a strange
opening usually called the vulture maybe
I'm completely capturing the soprano she
asian the vulture and I only know that
this is the possible line yes yeah do we
understand this is just a bit of a
strange opening but it's not as bad as
it looks which is probably not telling
much as it looks pretty horrific but it
is it is playable it's not totally
totally bad I mean this is the position
of our white space advantage everything
but it's not like I'm winning it's just
comfortable okay um do it go f4 here is
this is this taking it too far well it
looks it looks sensible to open up the
position and make some use of this c3
Bishop if it takes I think Queen d2 will
get it back you still took maybe first
Knight f3 yeah why not
I mean it's it's it's tough to keep f4
and long run I mean it's not like you
can easily play g5 flag in the King's
gambit maybe I shouldn't even try to
keep it back so to get it back so
quickly just try to play Bishop d3 short
castles a five or later Queen d2 or
queen takes a for us to develop yeah now
it's got 95 coming hmm
okay i'm going to i'm going to regain
the pawn now if he also Knight e5 now
Queen f4 night xf3 I can consider gtex
should be quite nice for white one issue
is that he wants to play Bishop e7 but
okay this is just blundering g7 and how
do you get your pieces out well maybe
black can play as it looks a bit
unattractive but maybe you can play F
695 Bishop e7 and just and just accept
this slide slightly uncomfortable
probably okay my tags sorry a queen
takes our form oh he's going back when
that I have some doubts about I'm I'm
ready to push here the edge for and
stuff ok I'll go here and still you
cannot really play Bishop e7 I think
yeah well h4 h5 yeah it has it has some
concrete problems for black if your
plate which should be 70 H 595 I take
take g7 so this is not really playable
and if you cannot play Bishop e7 it's
it's really awkward ok Bishop to d7
don't really want to cancel long here no
can do that it's not totally totally
insane
can take and play Bishop to g4 or for a
good structure not sure if I have
anything better yeah well h6 g6 I don't
really think it leads to much ok I've
keep it simple
yeah if he takes with the f porn which
is what I expect on a play Bishop okay
play Bishop b2 2g form he didn't do that
yeah it's just the same still try to get
rid of my light squared Bishop I have
basically all pawns on light squares and
should be a pretty pretty healthy
structure okay so let's let's see take
it should I take myself or do I have a
good alternative mmm castling do a
castle short actually maybe maybe
my king is still relatively safe here
and have this h6 idea trying to
undermine this pawn chain
yeah it's flexible on a three it can go
to g3 at the right moment this rook and
sometimes this h6 idea bye-bye white
might give some play against the eff
pond ok let's consider judges took
everyone just am sensible strengthening
move ok so why did he do that actually
now because ok wants to protect against
h6 i see i see so i can actually i can
take and play Queen age three check not
sure that this is the best way to play
but it keeps control with Queens off Jim
yeah it should always preserve some sort
of advantage the Queen trade
okay if I take it 1d seven and then look
aged 3 s's i can go Brooke h ad or f
right possibly jack okay but then i'm
almost committed to the Queen trade
anyway okay i can i can start with G for
actually and threatening g42 g5 so I
don't think that rook h8 is any good
because of g5
and then root age 3 next move
yeah the whole position is based on the
fact that I have them wow wow okay if I
take f5 he takes with the check I see
that okay before i do any egg I could
take you can play that move i'm going to
play it anyway so I'm about I can't put
it on the board well gfgf check was the
point but since it's just a good end
game now I don't see how we can prevent
that I'll that I'll probably get to the
e4 pawn or the g4 porn if he takes on g4
now maybe there's also RTF takes you for
this also the moves look F 7 which is
looking quite attractive but i think i
just take take on f8f8f8 bishop f8 and
then a bishop f perform should f4 then
the King advances smooth yeah maybe not
100% sure that it's a win it's very
clear a very very near
you know the e4 pawn I mean it's very
weak it really should win in a way but I
don't see it at the moment ok now I see
it actually this is what I need to do
Bishop e7 I go Bishop f4 and then I can
I can advance with my king I think that
that's it or even be should have six
push about 600 Bishop f6 this Bishop d6
he's got Bishop f8 though maybe maybe
this was actually not good aha Bishop f8
back to a fade king bishop f8 he's got
this tempo on the beep horn so Bishop
evade king after Bishop g7 tempo on the
beep on I can play King III be should be
talking you forward I am not positive
that I'm winning this position
the energy fine I should have thought
about that a bit longer I forgot that
after this zone after he provokes here
this g5 Bishop f4 stuff that he can
really return to have eight now
yeah and this I also underestimated
amazingly enough the King opponent game
is not winning
take skin test key after key five King
III I can only do anything with g6
stakes and kini for then he can just
play King d66 till hell freezes over Wow
nah that's disappointing after f5 this
is really an insane move freely
assistance is crazy f5 but i'd simply i
simply played this too quickly yeah you
should really take a bit of time to to
calculate stuff like that not good not
good at all
what entity if the Pawn g5 is also on a
dark square yeah it's b3 is also
question but if this is a good i mean i
wanted to avoid this temple
I don't really see how to how to get to
the e4 pawn I already don't kingi for
Bishop f4 I mean yeah I mean yeah not
even this would be good
well she playing for window I don't
maybe oh maybe but
you know if I take it
yeah I wonder if I can take it if i take
it king d 5 i've got a 4 if I this is
really quick I mean and ce4 is
questionable Bishop d4 might be a move
like takes on b5 kindy 5a for Bishop
deform yeah i don't i cannot i cannot
evaluate that but it's not clear to me
okay
I was really expecting before trying to
shut it completely down here I actually
have an additional idea i can try to
play Bishop g2 a5d 8 f 6 going all the
way around might be a might be good
actually okay King f4 takes King e5
that's not winning unfortunately it
really isn't
if I go Bishop f4 but what is he doing
after that probably moving the King up
there should be five I can I can take
and play a 3 which should win I
shouldn't do it actually hmm a 3 a 4 a 4
King f4 take takes King e5 yeah this
won't this will not win ok check
right looking at form should be three
and probably then my idea was Bishop b5
yeah it's not really leading to much
count he can even play that yeah that's
true the sugar 60 can take and play g5
it's not really good to say the least ok
I can I can do that making it a bit more
tricky if I'm for the end game if you
need to lose this temple move with the a
porn I can play King fo no of course I
can play King our fault this temple was
very crucial yeah silly yeah not knowing
and I'm getting the pawn completely saw
this really late yeah Bishop f4 and take
it
yeah I'm not not sure about the Zen game
probably across the draw black resigns
let's um let's look look at this I mean
just to to show the rest of it i will
hero he has no way to keep the porn and
let's say something like that the
problem is that at the end there is also
see five week and you have no way way to
defend this I wonder here
I was really expecting him to do to play
before it keeps more on the dark squares
i know but i'm not sure if I can do any
any sort of can make any headway here
just keeping everything closed I don't I
don't really know the question is now is
this what is this is this a window I
draw this what I could really didn't
appreciate it all is check that here i
have this move I mean here even I could
have I could have played this here even
okay a six and i'm going to always got
this one
Bishop to h6 is quite funny so it wasn't
winning at this moment computer gives
Bishop v8 or this is still way to add
when we should be
yeah this is what we had seen with this
computer gives this also as a winning
okay I'm threatening king F form
not quite sure yet how to how to
actually win that the computer says I'm
winning the e4 pawn but I'm not quite
sure how this is actually doable maybe
now you can go all the way round I mean
this b5 didn't help him here because he
has got an additional weakness here
I don't really see how to do that I was
right actually winning this position I I
don't see it I really don't see it the
computer is on 2.4 but I don't I don't
see how I'm winning the e4 pawn this is
the computer line and here I'm just
going here what what what's your point
I'm just staying here I don't understand
the line the computer always wants to
play stuff like that you just totally
idiotic why not why not just repeat him
and room how do you actually I get get
anywhere you can do that and once here I
don't I don't see a win I really don't
despite the 2.4 evaluation is there
something entirely different possible I
mean it was helpful that he had to play
a 6 because I've got more potential
temple moves on the on the queenside iam
maybe something like that just try to to
yeah this is actually ok but why wasn't
this possible earlier just to go around
20 hmm i'm really not one hundred
percent sold on this I mean it should
win in a way but I don't I don't see how
I don't see how ok OH after a 6 a-6 you
can provoke all the time that's clear
I don't see it despite our company
valuation how do is write winning here
okay i need to stop the video here i
need to stop it and i will try to look
at this in some detail and maybe do a
separate separate analysis on that it's
quite quite quite strange I don't see it
at the mood okay yeah it was it was of
course a complicated and here it's
really f5 looks really crazy but it's
it's probably the case that here this is
a mistake simply I should have thought
for a moment and and consider the
alternatives because it's maybe better
to not exchange everything off I mean
this is wait check I was just misjudging
the endgame this is the possible move
that is probably better if I mean what
is this is the threat what is black
doing now you go here you just stay on
the seventh intending d6a this is
terrible terrible position yeah it's
much much better much better what I
thought that this this is a win in a way
but it is it seems that it isn't even if
the computer gives it as a win but okay
here Bishop d6 was immediately
equalizing going to the king and porn
and Kim okay I'll do a separate video on
that if this is interesting okay thanks
for watching